well what we need to do in this country
is build build for the future build the
big infrastructure we need if we're
going to go on providing jobs and
opportunities in Britain and that means
I think trying to get these decisions
out of the day-to-day political argument
and have a big independent view that
everyone can sign up to and Andrew
adonus has stopped being a laborer peer
he was a labor transport secretary he's
going to be an independent peer chairing
this independent commission that will
give us impartial advice and then we can
get on and do what this country needs to
do which is get building yesBut
chancellor and there's another name
coming into my head here Howard Davis
remember him he was the guy that you
know he had the consultation about
Heathrow Airport and I and many other
people have interviewed him on this
program with his findings and he said
Heathrow good idea what did you do about
that kicked it into touch didn't you
well Betty I think this is a very good
example Howard Davis did a report very
recently on the options for where a new
runway should be in the South East of
England and he is forced the political
parties to look at that report and make
a decision so we've we've ended these
sort of endless debate about all the
different possible locations it could be
and it's come down to some very simple
choices that this independent Howard
Davis Commission has given us I think
that's not a bad model for the kind of
decisions we want to see taken in the
future which is independent advice very
clear set of options you know here I am
in the Manchester you know let's have a
high-speed railway line between
Manchester and Leeds across the Pennine
so to make the northern powerhouse
connected up let's see the options from
the independent report so we don't have
politicians arguing for 20 years about
where the line should go but Syd so to
avoid argument you just ignore them as
in Davis's case no no we're not ignoring
Davis we are at the moment you know and
we've got two more processes as they're
all these legal processes which you well
know that if we did not follow we'd be
straight in the court buy from those who
don't want to see things built okay
absolutely going to make a decision but
it's a great example of having
that independent advice forcing the
politicians to make a decision and it
comes to a bigger point that's for our
country you know are we going to be bold
about the future are we going to build
are we going to make sure our banking
system works for people are we going to
live within our means as a country these
are the decisions that we need to take
if we're going to go on delivering
security for working people and higher
living standards okay we could just be
mischievous with you chancellor then I
mean you say you're taking it out of the
political agenda other people may look
at you and say you're so not you have
stolen adonus to get right up jeremy
corbyn's knows and to weaken him know a
Drude onus is someone who even though he
was a labor cabinet minister actually
did a lot to try and build consensus on
things like the high speed to project
and the cross rail project which was
being built in London at the moment and
I was able to finish the job that he
started on something like cross rail so
I think he's a really good person to do
this job and I think it shows you know
general confidence that the country is
heading in the right direction and we've
got the right arrangements as a country
to make these decisions that he wants to
come and work with us as chairs this new
independent body and by the way he is
starting work today that work starts
right now we're not waiting time to to
set up the office and you know get the
computers in and we're all ready to go
and the work starts today okay that
starts today
Wight Lloyd's we're just getting
breaking news on Lloyd's today and you
say you're going to make two billion
pounds with the shares available to the
public why does not start today why are
you waiting until next year to do that
one well we've got a big task here which
is to finally get the British government
out of owning great chunks of our
banking system and we've made a lot of
progress with Lloyds but this final
chunk this final sale will be the
biggest privatisation in over 20 years
and I don't want to all of those shares
to go to city institutions I want them
to go to members of the public people
watching this program and others and so
our offer is this by Lloyds shares will
favor small investors will favour those
who hold the shares for a long time
you'll get a discount and we'll help
create that share owning democracy that
we want to see
in this country yeah and the process of
getting the paperwork ready making sure
that prospectus is there yeah
takes a little bit of time because those
are the rules that the shares will be
coming on sale very soon and as of now
there is a website available where
people can register on the dot-gov
website to make sure they're kept
informed and that they can get in there
and get these shares with the discount
okay